عاشق يعزف الجيتار ومنديل مطعم صنع مسيرته
تفاصيل غريبه في حياه ميسي
يبدو ليونيل ميسي رجلا بسيطا للغايه رغم
كل ما حققه من انجازات في كره القدم وهو
الامر الذي يجعله يستمتع بحياته كرجل بسيط
خارج اطار اسطوريته الكرويه ورغم توفر
الكثير من المعلومات عن مسيرته وحياته
الشخصيه الا ان هناك بعض الاشياء التي
يجهلها كثيرون حول ميسي تفاصيل منها ما
صنع مسيرته في كره القدم ومنها ما اعتاد
الهروب اليه من كره القدم
[موسيقى]
عام 2000 كان ليونيل ميسي يطرق ابواب
انديه اوروبا من اجل ايجاد نادي يضمه
وقتها راه كارلوس وانبهر بامكانياته وخشي
ان يضمه اي نادي قبل برشلونه فقام باغرب
طريقه ممكنه من اجل التوقيع معه خصوصا وان
المفاوضات بين والد اللاعب خورخيميسي وبين
النادي الكتالوني امتدت لاشار واثناء
تواجدهم في نادي بومباي للتنس وفي المطعم
الخاص للنادي قرر كارلوس ريكاش ان تتم
الصفقه على مسؤوليته الشخصيه وجلب منديلا
من المطعم لكي يتم توقيع اول عقد احترافي
في مسيره ليونيل ميسي والذي بمقتضاه اصبح
لاعبا لبرشلونه والباقي يعرفه الجميع
اعترف ميسي ذات مره بالطريقه التي يهرب
بها من الضغوطات واتضح انه يفعل ذلك عبر
العزف على الجيتار ميسي لا يعرف كثيرا عن
طرق العزف وليس محترفا بما يكفي ولكنه يحب
لعب الاغاني الهادئه حتى تمنحه الموسيقى
التي يعزفها السلام النفسي وتطرد الافكار
المشوشه من راسه ربما كما تمنح الموسيقى
التي يعزفها بالكره الشعور ذاته لجماهير
كره القدم
[موسيقى]
يمكن ان تكون العلاقه بين ليونيل ميسي
وزوجته انتونيلا مرجعا لكتاب السيناريو
الذين يبحثون عن قصص الحب والرومانسيه
لتقديمها للجمهور ليتعرف على انتونيلا في
السابعه من عمره عبر صديق مشترك في
روزاريو يدعى
وفي منزله نشا الحب بينهما من اول نظره
وبعد سفره الى اسبانيا كان لي يتحدث معها
هاتفيا مره كل اسبوع ولكنها كانت دائما في
عقله وقلبه كما قال لدرجه انه حين توفيت
صديقتها ترك ميسي اسبانيا وعاد خصيصا الى
الارجنتين ليكون بجوارها في ذلك الموقف
ويظهر لي دوما وهو يحتضنها في كل
الاحتفالات ليبرز الجانب الرومانسي في
شخصيته والذي يختبئ وراء سحره الكروي وعلى
ذكر انتونيلا فقد اكد ميسي انه لا يحب
مشاهده كره القدم رغم كونه ساحرها والسبب
ان حبيبته تشعر بالملل من المباريات لذلك
يفضل ان مشاهده افلام الكرتون رفقه
الاطفال للاستمتاع بوقت عائلي دافئ
اعترف لي انه يحب ممارسه العاب الفيديو
الخاصه بكره القدم مع العديد من لاعبيها
عبر الانترنت ولكنه يخفي عن هويته
للاستمتاع باللعب دون ان يعرف من يواجهه
انه في مواجهه مع ليونيل ميسي ليؤكد انه
يحقق الفوز غالبا والعهده على الراوي
بالطبع ولكن على ما يبدو فان سحر كره
القدم تجاوز اقدامه ووصل الى اصابعه ايضا